we are talking this evening with the top
media representatives for each of the
presidential candidates first up tonight
t.j ducklow national press secretary for
the biden campaign t.j thanks for being
on
hey brett thanks for having me you heard
peter's piece i want to start with what
the former vice president specifically
would have done at the end of january
had he received the briefing that we
know now the president received january
28th
sure well brett we know that you know
here we are in the united states of
america
we are four percent of the world's
population
we are 20 uh of the coba cases we are 25
of the cova deaths and we now know from
bob woodward's reporting as you just
covered
that this president knowingly and
willfully
lied about the dangerousness of the
threat that faced this country
uh we know from columbia university had
this president taken action just a few
weeks earlier
we would have tens of thousands of lives
that would have been saved you know
while the president was out there
calling it
a hoax while he was saying that the
virus would magically disappear
he knew he knew brett he knew that that
how dangerous
uh the threat that we are facing was joe
biden joe biden from the very beginning
in march
has put out very clear plans about what
he would do to get our country
we're talking about in january because
here are his two top advisors
two of them that are he listens to
closely ron klain
and zeke emanuel on january 28th and
january 30th
would you ban chinese travelers from
arriving in the united states
i wouldn't i think that's premature
everyone in america should take a very
big
uh breath slow down and stop uh
panicking and being his and it goes on i
mean they continue to make comments that
mass are not necessary at the moment
this is overreaction that goes into
february and early march
so understanding that those are the
people he listens to and joe biden has
said he wouldn't have closed
the travel from china what specifically
would
the former vice president have done well
let's get a few things straight uh the
vice president was not against the
travel ban first of all second of all
let's remember an important uh brett
let's remember an important distinction
donald trump was the president of the
united states it was on donald trump i'm
asking you to take joe biden
it was on donald trump it was on donald
trump he would take action
to actually protect the american people
he closed the joke traveled joe biden
wrote an op-ed in usa today in january
warning that the threat was coming joe
biden said in february that donald trump
should get people
on the ground in china what did what did
donald trump do donald trump was
praising china
donald trump was praising president xi's
response saying that they had it under
control
when clearly he knew as we now know from
bob woodward they did not have it under
control
he should have been protecting the
american people he should have been
putting real plans in place so let me
just clarify confront this incredibly
dangerous understand let me just clarify
you're saying that joe biden
was for closing down travel from china
when the president did it
uh joe biden has been clear and i can
send you the fact checks if they're
helpful
brett joe biden has been clear that he
was not against that travel ban but he
was for it
joe biden has been clear about this
brett again i can send i can send you
the fact checks
if they're helpful this has been fact
checked into oblivion okay i'm just
asking you the question
you're saying yes he was for the china
travel ban when the president
implemented it two 48 hours after
receiving that briefing
the important thing about the travel ban
yes no yes i know and i know
brett i know that you all like to cite
the travel brand i know no no the
president does that's why i'm bringing
it up
obviously it's going to be in the debate
brett hold on the important thing to
know about the travel ban
is that even after the president
implemented that travel ban
tens or says that he implemented it tens
of thousands of people
came in and out of i'm gonna take it
that you're not gonna answer that
question you're gonna send me some fact
checks
okay trump doing brett he was he was
ignoring the violence the fact
in china go ahead let's continue to fast
check here's what dr fauci said when
asked if there was a discrepancy
with what the president said privately
and what the president said publicly
i may not be tuned in to the right thing
that they're talking about
but i didn't really see any
discrepancies between what he told
us and what we told him and what he
ultimately came out publicly and said
so is dr fauci wrong brett i i know that
it's
you all are working overtime to try to
find excuses for this president we know
from the president's own words
he knew how serious this threat was he
did not implement the necessary steps to
get testing to where we needed to get
contact tracing to where we needed
to uh to actually mobilize ppe and get
that around to hospitals around the
country
this president failed the american
people when we needed it most
okay i'm just asking you specific
questions about what's happening over
the past couple of days joe biden has
said and you mentioned it
that if president trump had asked it two
weeks earlier
54 000 lives would have been saved in
march and april but if president trump
acted two weeks earlier
and shut everything down super tuesday
primaries
would have been affected wouldn't they
and making it harder for biden to catch
bernie sanders to become the nominee
you were not calling he was not calling
for the the stop of the super tuesday
primaries
well again brett i will remind you of
the distinction i made earlier which is
that
donald trump is the president i know but
had he acted your kind might not be the
nominee correct
i i i understand that it's my it might
be useful to like engage in
hypotheticals like that you are doing
donald trump was the president he had
the information he lied about it it's
quite simply that simple
okay let me move on you had an interview
today the
former vice president did he told jake
tapper that he would raise corporate
taxes on day one
in office regardless of the unemployment
rate
what it was at the time one is that good
politics and two how would he do that
well look i think the vice president has
been clear um that he is going to stand
up for the middle class
that he is going to be there for working
families uh and that he is going to
prioritize them in everything he does
as you know brett you all have covered
um the vice president rolled out his
plan
for an economic recovery in july how
we're going to build back this country
not just to where we were before the
coronavirus but to build the economy
um it's you know it's something that we
talk often about um because that's one
of the jobs of the
as of the president is to get americans
back to work in the middle
of this of this economic crisis as well
as this pandemic there will be a lot of
time to go into specifics i wanted to
ask you about nafta and what he said
about all of that today because it's
important a lot of states
but i want to keep it fair on time end
with this has joe biden ever used a
teleprompter during local interviews
or to answer q a with supporters bret we
are not going to engage this is
this is straight from the trump campaign
exactly they're using it and what it
does
and what it does brett is it's trying to
distract the american people i'm just
they're using it they talk about it
every day can you say yes or no that's
because they talk about it every day
brad because they don't have
a coherence well you have an answer yes
or no
brett they talk about it every day
because they don't have a coherent
argument for why donald trump deserves
re-election deserves four more years
we know that he lied to the american
people we know that he has not
uh shown leadership during this crisis
and they are desperate to throw anything
they can against the wall to try to
distract from that fact i understand but
you can't answer the question
but i am not going to allow the trump
campaign to funnel their questions
through fox news and get me to respond
to that well tj we appreciate your time
and thank you for coming on
thanks brett